Компанія Nord Stream 2 готується відновити прокладку труб "Північного потоку-2". Попередня дата старту робіт - 5 грудня.
Утім, оглядачів здивувало, що ці роботи планують почати, так би мовити, з кінця - у німецькій частині шельфу Балтійського моря.
Причому йдеться про ділянку протяжністю лише 2,5 кілометри.
Відомий російський експерт з питань енергетики Михайло Крутіхін не вірить, що "Північний потік-2" буде добудовано.
У Росії оголосили, що, мовляв, 2,5 кілометри цього газопроводу, біля берегів Німеччини, все-таки побудують. Дві його нитки.
Але сенс - у тому, щоб з'єднати ці дві нитки з основною трасою, яка закінчилась в районі острова Борнгольма, який належить Данії.
І ось роботи у морі неможливі, доки не знайдеться підприємство-трубоукладач, готове кинути виклик американским санкціям.
Тому укладати там 2 кілометри труб невідомо для чого - це чиста показуха.
Експерти пояснюють, чому це схоже радше на піар-акцію, ніж на завершення будівництва.
Адже для реалізації проєкту залишилося прокласти не два, а ще 75 кілометрів трубопроводу.
Решту із загалом понад 1200 кілометрів підводного шляху росіяни з європейцями встигли протягнути ще до грудня 2019 року.
І тоді, через оголошення санкцій США проти учасників проєкту, будівництво було призупинене, і вже рік роботи у морі не ведуться.
Відновити російсько-європейський проєкт, попри санкції Сполучених Штатів вимагають керівники федеральної землі Мекленбург-Передня Померанія.
Трубопровід майже готовий. Завершено 97 відсотків, і, звичайно ж, ми ведемо перемовини,
зокрема, із керівництвом Nord Stream 2, про можливості завершення цього газопроводу.
Зауважмо, що із 75 кілометрів, яких бракує, близько 60 кілометрів - у водах Данії, а 16 кілометрів - у виключній економічній зоні ФРН.
Активізувати нині планують саме німецьку ділянку.
Однак до останнього часу Nord Stream 2 не розповідав, яке ж судно опускатиме труби у море
замість суден швейцарської компанії, які були виведені з Балтійського моря через загрозу американських санкцій.
У російських ЗМІ майбутнім укладальником труб "Північного потоку-2" називають російське судно "Академік Черський".
Однак чому на його залучення довелося чекати так довго - фактично цілий рік?
"Академік Черський" працював на іншому проєкті на Сахаліні, де діаметр труби був меншим.
І його треба було модернізувати, адже на "Північному потоці-2" діаметр труби є більшим.
Судячи з усього, це буде така ж показуха, як з тим, аби перегнати судно "Академік Черський" зі сходу в Балтійське море.
Довго ялозити його незрозуміло як.
Решта вкрита таємницею, що збирається "Газпром" робити практично, а не просто оголошуючи, що ми добудуємо проєкт.
Тут повне мовчання.
США тим часом готують нові санкції проти "Північного потоку-2".
За даними Wall Street Journal, ці санкції будуть націлені на компанії, які займаються переобладнанням,
а також на підприємства, які повинні страхувати, інспектувати й сертифікувати газопровід.
Члени Конгресу США дійшли згоди про нові обмеження, аби "поховати" "Північний потік-2", пише американська газета й відзначає,
що "ці нові санкції можуть означати перемогу для українців, які лобіювали власні інтереси у Вашингтоні, аби знищити російський газопровід".
Опитані DW експерти впевнені, що Джо Байден після вступу на посаду президента США
продовжить жорстку політику Дональда Трампа щодо цієї труби.
І різниця буде лише у тоні дискусії Вашингтона з Берліном.
Тон Байдена стане більш ввічливим, на противагу Трампу, який до позиції ФРН щодо "Північного потоку-2" не дослухався взагалі.
Ця комбінація ввічливості й діалогу з тиском і санкціями буде стосуватися усієї політики США щодо Росії за Байдена, вважають експерти.
Він відчуває, що знає, як розмовляти з Володимиром Путіним, коли це йому потрібно.
І як вводити штрафні заходи й санкції, коли це необхідно.
І він відзначав, що буде як вести діалог, так і застосовувати санкції.
Наприклад, він каже, що подовжить Договір про стратегічні наступальні озброєння СНО-3. Це й Путін має намір зробити.
І, схоже, що так і станеться до завершення терміну дії угоди в лютому.
Водночас я не думаю, що Байден одразу ж буде скасовувати санкції проти Росії.
Він буде їх використовувати для тиску в якості інструменту для досягнення прогресу щодо України, невтручання в вибори тощо.
У компанії Nord Stream 2 жодних деталей стосовно продовження робіт не повідомляють.
Водночас експерти не очікують у разі відновлення робіт введення нових санкцій. Мовляв, і старі добре працюють.